voilà premier débat sur la situation
militaire mais aussi sur les réponses
aux européennes avec mes invités
guillaume klossa bonsoir vous seriez
vous êtes le fondateur d'europanova
ancien sherpa au conseil européen
notamment lors de la précédente
présidence française de l'union et
conseil spécial lors de la présidence le
précédent conseiller spécial c'était ça
votre type la présidence française c'est
intéressant parce qu'on y ait de nouveau
donc votre cette présidence où il ya
plein de crise quand exactement ça se
ressemble aussi d'une certaine façon
l'histoire se répète tél patricia
allemonière bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes grand reporter spécialiste de
politique internationale
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique à mes côtés et puis je suis
toujours transparent avec vous on
entendait le général pellistrandi qui au
dernier moment nous a annoncé qu'il
était retenu au ministère des armées
c'est pas très agréable mais ce sont des
choses qui arrivent bref je vous prie je
voulais démarrer de toute façon par une
question un peu général c'est la
cinquième journée de ce conflit quel
bilan vous faites de cette journée
patricia je commence avec vous alors
d'abord la guerre dure
après je pense alors ma propre patte sur
le plan tactique militaire on a
l'impression que la la demo cousine
après avoir un peu attendu l'un sur
certaines villes en particulier au nord
car qu'il est bien il a décidé de passer
une autre phase par ce qui scellèrent
l'artillerie maintenance etc plus donc
les bombardements sont plus massifs plus
aveugle et dont il ne peut plus tenir le
discours de comment cibler uniquement
sur des civils a retiré on sait ce que
c'est un fait et c'est vraiment très
aveugle mais donc ça touche forcément
les civils
la deuxième le deuxième axe de la
journée je crois que c'est ce qui se
passe sur un plan diplomatique
où l'on voit que l'aïe une intense
activité de nouveau le président
français a parlé à parler justement à
vladimir poutine et l'un avec cette idée
protégeons les civils
cette ce grand souci de protection des
civils qu'ils soient ukrainiens ou
d'ailleurs étrange et ceux qui veulent
prendre la suite est notamment les
centaines de français sont toujours là
bas troisième volet c'est les sanctions
avec des pays comme la suisse qui
rejoignent le concert des nations
européennes occidentales et là on a
l'impression qu'il ya quelque chose qui
skie ceux qui se font mais qui fait bloc
enfin j'en finirai par toujours cette
menace nucléaire
tout le monde a en tête les propos de
vladimir poutine ce week-end et cette
non réponse américaine qui essaie
d'éviter les ce canal parce que si à
force d'avancer d'avancé comme le faible
animé routine comment va-t-il s'il est
acculé reculer et doit c'est toute la
difficulté et enfin évidemment les
négociations qui ont en cours mais ça je
pense qu'on va parler vous avez des
questions ou pas mais j'ai aimé en
dernier parce que j'y crois moins vous
avez posé les grands chapitres de ce
premier débat
guillaume klossa je voudrais faire un
focus sur l'inde et l'une des infos dont
parlait patricia ces négociations entre
une délégation russe une délégation
ukrainienne à la frontière bélarus moi
j'ai eu presque la surprise de lire il
ya quelques minutes en cette fin d'après
midi que il y avait un second round qui
était qui était prévu alors que on a
presque une impression de jeu c'est pas
j'allais dire gesticulations de termes
et mba est un petit peu fort mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut attendre de négociation
comme celle là dans un contexte comme
celui-là ce qu'est ce qui est ce qui est
très étonnant c'est une négociation lieu
mais le premier le président de l'unss
qui a dit qu'il en attendait strictement
rien donc chacun veut montrer à son
opinion publique qui fait des efforts et
la vérité c'est qu'il ya une machine de
propagande russe qui est extrêmement
forte al à l'aide à destination du
peuple russe nous ne savons pas ce
serait vraiment intéressant de faire une
analyse de ce qui se dit sur les chaînes
publiques russes parce que les autres
médias n'ont pas le droit de prendre
d'autres informations que les
informations officielles qui sortent de
deux agences est allé les textes et les
images donc je pense que le le sujet
c'est de montrer par rapport à un
narratif que nous ne connaissons pas que
nous sommes en train de négocier nous
sommes de bonne volonté c'est ce que
veut montrer et de l'autre côté
les ukrainiens veulent aussi montrer
qu'ils sont deux sont de bonne volonté
qui cherchent une solution qui sont donc
il ya il ya un jeu de dupes qui est en
train de se se passer mais c'est aussi
pour les ukrainiens
moyen de sonder les négociateurs et
l'entourage parce que personne n'est sûr
en fait que vladimir poutine et vraiment
suivi j'ai pas suivi le soutien vire
vraiment réussi quoi dans le comique
dans le premier set personne n'est
vraiment sûr et ce qu'on sait c'est que
manifestement
les jeunes qui sont de l'armée donc qui
ont été
engagées sont partis pour non pas
annexée
l'ukraine mais récupérée à des
territoires soit disant russe et qui
découvrent qu'ils ont une autre feuille
de route et qui sont très mal à l'aise
je sais pas si vous avez vu l'anecdote
kinder weekender cette application eh
bien figurez vous que des jeunes femmes
ukrainiennes ont localisé les troupes
russes parce que les jeunes les jeunes
foot militaires russes chercher à faire
des affaires des des rencontres ah oui
c'est pas tout à fait la même qualité je
pense que je pense qu'ils sont
complètement déphasé et je pense aussi
que donc ça explique peut-être aussi
décalage entre ce qu'on imaginait d'une
guerre éclair ultra efficace d'une armée
au risque allait être à kiev en deux
jours et faire tomber des lignes ce qui
est la situation des jeunes russes n'ont
pas envie de faire la guerre mais ce
sont même elles sont engagés parce qu'il
ya le service mythique star mais n'ont
pas forcément envie donc je pense que
c'était le plus plus compliqué que ça et
tout d'un coup on se rend compte qu'il
ya une société de russes qu'il faut
maîtriser et je pense que même poutine
n'avait pas idée que il y avait une
autre réalité générationnel parce qu'il
à près de 70 ans et puis il ya une jeune
génération qui suit larry david hill
après 70 ans les deux pays connectés et
le
la diabolisation de l'ennemi tels que le
faible a dit mi-août il fait toujours
dans ces guerres ce qui est finie
c'était contre les terroristes en syrie
c'était contre les djihadistes là c'est
contre des nazis soi disant c'est
précisément pour un peu on peut pas dire
on va faire la guerre aux ukrainiens au
fait la guerre à des nazis parce que
parce que tout il ya des familles qui
sont très interconnectés qui sont pas
reliées entre elles parfois d'ailleurs
je n'étais pas le but de faire la guerre
aux ukrainiens s'étaient de d'enlever 2d
chapeauté en quelque sorte le
gouvernement il est demandé mais les
ukrainiens en théorie on leur faisait
pas la guerre effectivement qu'on vous
dit d'autant que ils sont cousins ils
sont parfaites en face enfin et on a
sans doute surestimé l'armée russe est
sous-estimée mais je craignais au delà
de la résistance il ya eu six contingent
depuis la guerre de la crimée en ukraine
si contingent chaque fois de 60000
personnes au qui ont donc ça fait vous
pouvez vous rendre au bout ça fait près
de 2 400 mille personnes ukrainiens qui
sont des vétérans de la guerre du nom
basse parce qu'ils ont été incorporés
puisant fernand et puis sont partis ils
ont parfois participé à des manoeuvres à
des opérations militaires
donc c'est pas juste d un boucher un
charcutier à un cordonnier sont des gens
et donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a
sans doute été sous-estimée autres cas
par nos opinions publiques occidentales
et peut-être aussi par la demi-heure
poutine ce qui est très intéressant en
fait c'est que pour l'opinion publique
européenne voilà je vais pas dire la
machine de propagande mais la machine de
communication du gouvernement ukrainien
est tout à fait remarquable parce
qu'elle est complètement connecté avec
les réseaux ukrainiens dans les
différents pays européens et qu'est ce
qu'on voit on voit des gens qui parlent
de valeurs de démocratie d'europe de
l'union européenne qui sont plus
européens que les européens qui parle
dans la langue des pays auxquels est
encore dans la eng des pays auxquels ils
s'adressent et qui sont capables
d'organiser dans beaucoup de villes du
corps de l'union de l'union parce qu'il
veut adhérer dans l'union il ya le
relais
et donc ça c'est très intéressant et
l'autre sujet très intéressant c'est
qu'on ce qu'on voit la qualité des
hommes politiques craignant le le
président et l'un ce qui compensait que
comique mais enfin et comme il ya une
intelligence tactique qui a une culture
que kiki à une croix du courage de
l'empathie qui même avec les les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'union qui
n'ont pas été aussi correct qu'il aurait
valu qui c'est qui celle et les les
prendre dans le sens du barça c'est
remarquable le vice-premier ministre en
charge du numérique que je connais
michael mais qu'at il fait de rohff qui
est un type remarquable qui a préparé
le pays face aux cyberattaques parce que
l'une des cibles principales c'étaient
les infrastructures internet et ça
résiste sa président les a beaucoup
aidés c'est aussi
j'étais j'ai débattu il ya quelques
semaines avec mireille fedorov
vice-premier ministre venant de la
société civile c'est intime absolument
remarquable et il était là pour
anticiper aussi parce que ces gens
anticipent le maire de le maire de kiev
aussi sportive de l'ancien boxeur est un
boxeur quelque chose qu'est ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est qu'on a
l'impression que cette société a
anticipé ces nous préparer à la fois
moralement et techniquement
à à résister ouais alors vous parliez
effectivement du président ukrainien
volodimir l'inscrivent ski on va on va
l'écouter parce que il est très présent
notamment sur les médias sociaux il sait
très bien en jouer et vous l'avez dit
c'est un ancien comique à l'ancien
humoriste mais
qui se révèle
et je trouve qu'il se révèle un état
aussi dans cette façon de communiquer
écouter laisser l'un de ses derniers
messages il s'adresse aux soldats russes
esata
déposez vos armes et partez d'ici
ne croyez pas vos commandant
ne croyez pas vos protagonistes sauver
vos vies et partez
patricia allemonière sait il se révèle
aux yeux du monde quand même ce
président en tout cas le prune stature
héroïque ça c'est certain oui il faut
savoir que peu de temps avant que tous
ces événements se déclencher les têtes
en chute libre dans les sondages parce
que il n'avait justement pas pu réaliser
ce qu'il avait promis en quelque sorte
et la lutte contre la corruption
règlement des questions du donbass ce
n'est pas je dis que ce n'était pas une
partie facile pour lui donc il est en
perte de vitesse est là avec cet
événement brusquement effectivement cet
homme je viens presque dire 7,1
médiatique de télé se révèle à son à son
peuple il sait se servir aussi des
outils merveilleusement bien et il est
ce que je trouve dans cette guerre c'est
qu'on a depuis le début une guerre qui
se joue ici sur l'empathie qui se joue
aussi sur l'affectif et cette empathie
et cet affectif ces données par le
président qui intervient régulièrement
qu'il a dans la rue qui parle aux
soldats qui parlaient en russe parfois
qui est comme la première longue et il
maîtrise parfaitement et puis on a tous
ces gens qui nous parlent à nous
européens que qui nous donnent des
témoignages qui sont tous ukrainiens et
qui nous touche parce que dans ce cas là
forcément le rock se reconnaît en eux et
on n'a pas les autres ce qu'on appelait
ce que certains payent les méchants
enfin les cons qu'on trouve côté
ukrainien parce qu'il n'ya pas que des
gentils garçons côté ukrainien et côté
donbass parce que moi il se lit sur le
terrain et je peux vous dire que j'ai vu
des gens non fréquentable des deux côtés
des gens qui se réclament
de mafia qui sont prêts à tuer père mère
et frère et soeur et tout le monde pour
obtenir simplement je ne sais pas pour
le plaisir de la violence déjà
excessivement violent et des gens très
violent aussi de l'autre côté qui
n'hésitent pas à faire le salut nazi
donc il ya une réalité qui ne faut pas
se cacher mais l'essentiel de la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est quand même ces gens
qui nous interpelle qui nous disent tu
es comme moi gamin tu pourrais recevoir
des bombes parce que il ne s'attendait
pas être bombardées et donc il nous
renvoie à nous parce que demain de
recevoir des bons donc on est proche oui
mais il faut dire que dans la société
ukrainienne y avait un combat entre le
bien et le mal ceux qui ont été élus qui
nous parle c'est plutôt le camp du bien
intrusion survient donc c'est pas c'est
pas les entre eux entre guillemets les
noms mais en revanche ce qui est très
intéressant moi je trouve dans la
manière on s'exprime le président
ukrainien ccx s'exprime avec une
économie de mots
absolument remarquable ses dires il dit
les choses de manière simple et on
aimerait et moi j'aimerais que nos
leaders politiques et cette même
capacité
il n'en parle pas et en même temps on
sent qu'il a le sens de l'histoire et ça
c'est très intéressant parce que je
pense que ça contribue aussi à cette
capacité de devenir action si vous avez
lu il ya quelques semaines ce livre
passionnant d'erik larson c'est ça
raconte sortie la première année de
churchill au au pouvoir donc c'est là la
période des bombardements sur sur
londres le titre c'est la splendeur et
l'infamie et donc ce qui est intéressant
c'est à l'alchimie entre la capacité de
résistance d'un peuple en l'occurrence
les londoniens mais pas seulement les
anglais qui sont bombardés toutes les
nuits et le
l'aspect charismatique d'un leader et
les mots que que tu chantes il réussit à
trouver dans cette première année bien
évidemment là c'est beaucoup trop tôt
pour faire une comparaison mathieu mais
quand même est ce que vous diriez que
poutine a pas vu venir cette alchimie la
2 qui est en train de se passer
et qui construit la résistance
ukrainienne en tout cas il ya un
contraste de communication qui
saisissant vous avez un vladimir poutine
qui paraît
figé comme une statue du musée grévin
digne des vieux leader soviétique
téléphone un fils avec eux alors que
l'autre communiquent par smartphone à
qui on vient faire des réciter un
compliment comme comme au bon vieux
temps j'allais dire enfin bon temps au
vieux temps de l'union soviétique
alors qu'en face vous avez un président
qui fait des scènes fille et
communiquent dans des lieux symboliques
avec ses troupes en tee shirt enfin le
contraste est saisissant et
manifestement oui la bataille de la
communication à
visée de l'international elle est gagnée
par l'ukraine à plate couture enfin je
suis pas certain que vladimir poutine
s'attendait à une grande popularité de
son initiative est une opération de
guerre n'ont pas de bonnes
communications pour une opération paille
lui il est plutôt avisé interne il veut
gagner la bataille intérieure pour
maintenir l'opinion publique russe
derrière lui et derrière cette opération
militaire à cette guerre qu'ils lancent
alors que en ukraine il faut évidemment
que le pays soit derrière ce présent
mais lui il vit surtout les communautés
marginales pour émouvoir obtenir de la
quille alors justement on va on va
parler ils semblent sûrs d'économique
tout de suite là aussi frappé par des
sanctions qui viennent du monde entier
de toutes dernières informations elle
vient
de londres les ports britanniques fermés
aux navires sous pavillon russe on va
parler de ces sanctions tout de suite
avec avec nous en duplex christine
dugoin clément qui est chercheuse
associée
à la chaire risque de l'iae paris
sorbonne business clown vous publiez
influencé manipulation des conflits
armées modernes aux guerres économiques
c'est chez v à édition bonsoir merci de
ceux d'être avec nous peut-être
un retour général sur ce train de
sanctions est ce que vous le qualifié
d'historique
bonjour si vous voulez ces sanctions ont
été
particulièrement marquante au niveau de
l'union européenne et ce qui est à
peut-être été le plus le plus marquant
est le plus fort c'est la décision de
livrer des armes létales qui a été
annoncé par madame von der leyen ça
c'est une première au niveau de l'union
européenne
et mine de rien dans ces sanctions et
bien il y a eu plusieurs tournants qui
sont des véritables changements en terme
de l'analyse de de l'union européenne et
de relations internationales c'est la
décision de l'allemagne deux constats de
données 2% de son pib à la défense et
surtout la position de la suisse qui
s'alignent et qui sort de sa neutralité
dont qui s'aligne sur les sanctions
européennes pour toucher la russie et
les actifs de certaines personnalités
donc là on a un signal qui est très fort
qui est alors qu'ils arrivent qui a mis
un petit peu de temps mais finalement à
l'échelle de ce qu'est l'union
européenne où on doit négocier à 27 qui
est dans un temps assez rapide la
fermeture complète des espaces aériens
est aussi particulièrement notable et ça
permet d'avoir un front uni ce qui
dénote aussi de la perception du degré
de manas qui est porté par ce conflit
c'est plus important ce que vous venez
de décrire que le fait de bannir les
banques russes ni de celui du système
d'échangés interbancaires ça vous semble
plus important non ça va avec si vous
voulez et je suis juste partie sur les
dernières les derniers événements qui
sont qui sont arrivés le changement du
système swift va clairement
handicapé l'économie russe mais va aussi
handicapé ces oligarques on le voit
certaines personnalités alors qu' il y à
un risque individuel assez fort à
s'exprimer sur une décision du kremlin
surtout quand on s'y oppose
disent souhaiter le retour de la paix ce
qui est une façon tout de même
relativement à relativement claire de
dire qu'ils ne soutiennent pas ce
conflit
même si ce n'est pas s'opposer de
manière de manière frontale puisqu'il y
a eu aujourd'hui des négociations qui
sont organisés en biélorussie ou du
moins une forme de négociation ça permet
aussi de garder une certaine protection
au niveau individuel laissant croire que
l'on va pouvoir espérer est que mais
c'est se positionner aussi et puis le
dernier point c'est que vous avez aussi
la population russe derrière tout cela
est que ces sanctions vont avoir un
impact
clairement le rouble est en train de
dévisser vous l'avez vu et cela risque
de continuer aussi le fait d'avoir des
banh de beaucoup de monnaie de plus
pouvoir facilement acheter donc assurer
des supply chain avoir des
problématiques surtout ce qui va être
vol maintenant les britanniques qui ont
annoncé la fermeture des ports donc là
on va avoir des problèmes de commerce et
de transport vont avoir un impact
or et bien quelque part si la population
russe
pour celles qui ne seraient pas dans une
dans une mouvance de ne pas soutenir ces
éléments enfin ces événements en ukraine
dont parfois ils n'ont qu'une
connaissance assez relative
je vous rappelle qu'il y a tout de même
eu une demande au niveau du kremlin de
ne pas qualifier et bien la guerre en
ukraine de guerre ce qui est quand même
un signal très fort si à un moment vous
avez beaucoup de mal à remplir le
frigidaire et bien vous avez un
mécontentement social et un mais qu'on
alors on a une petite rupture de liaison
avec christine dont 20 clément reviendra
vers vous dans un court instant
évidemment vous êtes avec nous jusqu'à
la fin de ceux de ce premier débat
guillaume klossa sûr je rebondis serait
ce que disait christine bohin clément
sur le l'europe le le changement que
vous c'est vraiment majeure le
changement de pied de l'europe sur le
fait de livrer des armes létales 2 et
est-ce que vous l'analysez de la même
façon je vais vous dire comment je sens
les choses d'abord je pense que le vent
de sympathie dans l'union européenne est
aussi due à la mobilisation remarquable
des ukrainiens dans tous les états
membres et man ils ont immobilisé ils
s'organisent sur l'ensemble du
territoire pas uniquement sur le dans
les capitales et c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose qui touche les opinions publiques
et notamment en suisse je les ressens
cette mobilisation il y aurait pas le
donc à un peuple qui a une diaspora
aussi dispersés en europe et qui est en
mouvement et ça ça touche c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose au
niveau des européens j'étais jeudi
dernier à une réunion de la présidence
française avec les responsables des
crimes organisés des états membres et
donc on a eu une grande discussion sur
ce qui est en train de se passer et il
ya eu à la fois un sentiment de solitude
parce que les américains ont quand même
dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il
n'interviendrait pas et ça ça a marqué
les esprits et les esprits est européen
et puis il ya eu le sentiment que la
grande histoire revenait moi ce que j'ai
entendu c'était l'esprit de munich vous
êtes en train de négocier il avait peur
que macro soit chamberlain et que tous
tous ces négociations face que
finalement on laisse et donc chez les
hongrois à chênée tchèque notamment qui
avaient le la mémoire il ya eu une
réaction une force remarquable et s'il
ya une unité cette fois ci c'est
peut-être pas tant la france et
l'allemagne que les européens de l'est
et c'est là qu'on voit la dig est
d'ailleurs allé non pas les y terminer
par c'est là qu'on voit que la dynamique
de l'union est intéressante parce que
tout d'un coup on est tous unis pour
faire des choses que seule l'union peut
faire
et qui était inconcevable la veille
parce que commander 2 je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle est quel est le fondement
juridique qui fait que la commission
européenne peut commander des armes je
ne sais pas quel est le fondement
juridique qui fait que la commission
européenne peut dire on va interdire
certaines news mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que ça s'est fait en concertation et
avec une unanimité entre les 27 états
membres qui vont mettre en oeuvre et
donc ça c'est unique et c'est un
comportement de de puissance qu'on
n'avait pas eu jusque avant et après on
peut dire qu'il ya une maturité depuis
douze ans depuis 15 ans parce qu'il ya
une série de crises qui pour forcer
européen à à s'organiser et à penser
mais ça peut être l'un des paradoxes de
cette première semaine de guerre c'est à
dire que finalement
l'union l'europe sort presque renforcer
ou semble sortir renforcée de ce conflit
est ce que vous diriez ça oui je dirais
qu'il y aura l'europe sort effectivement
totalement renforcer ce que ne voulait
surtout pas vladimir poutine qui cherche
depuis des années à diviser est bien là
s'est passé et ça va dans le sens de ce
que souhaitait effectivement le
président si français qui voulaient
justement reconstruire une europe de la
défense une europe capable de se
défendre alors là ça va bien sur bien
d'autres de secteurs mais ce qui est
très intéressant c'est de voir que
chaque pays prend des mesures comme les
anglais puis après les autres suivent
chacun y va de sa propre créativité j'ai
envie d'en temps c'est assez organisés
oui c'est aussi au réseau radio lorsque
si vous voulez on ne peut pas en europe
décidé unilatéralement de certaines
choses mais je parle des mesures
extérieurs à l'europe dans les pays
extérieurs à l'europe il ya certaines
mesures qui sont pris et puis après on
voit les européens et cette décision on
l'est on nous dit effectivement toujours
divisés en europe mais il faut remarquer
que chaque fois qu'il ya une crise
l'unité c'est moi ce que j'ai remarqué
il ya une unité chaque fois en face à
l'extérieur qui veut quand même d'être
cette europe qui est quand même très
profitable pour hbo bon nombre d'entre
nous et j'ai juste une remarque parce
que les thèmes de la campagne
présidentielle c'est lé thème que
poutine et les chinois peut souhaiter
c'est à dire le repli national la
souveraineté nationale thème du
président n'ont pas les thèmes du
président mais je les thèmes qui étaient
étaient dans les dents les nerfs débat
est donc c'est vraiment les thèmes
voulue par les nationalistes chinois
elena crioc et les nationalistes russes
qui ont fait un effort de comment dire
de soutien de stratégie auprès d'un
certain nombre de leaders d'opinion
d'extrême droite ou d'extrême gauche
depuis 20 ans pour asseoir ses thèmes
dans le débat public bon eh bien ça vous
savez c'est le thème de notre second
débat tout à l'heure
c'est quand même
c'est quand même intéressant de
comprendre que ces thèmes nous ont
quelque part été indien sur imposé à
l'extérieur que nous y sommes rentrés et
qu'une majorité et puis tout d'un coup
tout le monde sent que au final à leur
enfant alors on est dans un renforcement
des pouvoirs forts dans notre monde et
s'oppose à la démocratie mais ce que
j'avance avec une autre vient d'un autre
extrait pardon patricia de vous
interrompre un autre extrait d'une
déclaration du président ukrainien
olinger zelensky
il demande à intégrer l'union européenne
écoutez
nous nous adressons à lui en ce qui
concerne une intégration sans délai de
l'ukraine via une nouvelle procédure
spéciale nous sommes reconnaissants à
nos partenaires d'être à nos côtés
mais notre objectif est d'être avec tous
les européens et surtout d'être égaux
christine clément là la réponse quelle
peut être la réponse européenne face à
une demande comme comme celle là
il y avait déjà eu des des premiers
prémices de réponse qui était de dire
qu'une intégration et bien ne se faisait
pas aussi facilement et ce qui est sur
la table est plutôt de déclarer à de
reconnaître la candidature de l'ukraine
assez rapidement tout cela n'est encore
que poser est sur la table
l'intégration est un processus assez
long et une intégration que nous ferions
de manière aussi rapide serait-elle dans
le conflit de contexte que nous
connaissons
et qui est une qui est une guerre aux
frontières de l'ukraine et bien
risquerait de mettre un petit peu dans
l'embarras le processus pour les autres
états qui sont candidats depuis
plusieurs années on peut penser
notamment notamment à la serbie donc il
y a cette demande là il y a aussi
quelque part et je pense qu'il ne faut
pas se ne faut pas se leurrer des
sanctions ont été prises mais il ya une
crainte de la façon dont cela sera pris
par le kremlin qui avait annoncé lors
des déclarations initiales donc la
déclaration de cette guerre que toute
personne ou toute structure où tous pays
se mettant en travers de sa route et
bien serez considéré comme un adversaire
et devrait en assumer les conséquences
c'est l'argument qui a été repris quand
on parle de comportements agressifs
avant de mettre en place la force de
dissuasion donc il y as tout cela à mon
avis que les dirigeants doivent mesurer
puisque prendre des sanctions est allé
au delà est certes nécessaire si on veut
faire une démonstration de force et si
on veut faire une dissuasion qui soit
efficace et crédible mais il faudra
pouvoir en mesurer les conséquences
il y as tout cela qui va qui va se jouer
aussi bien au niveau des états mais
aussi bien au niveau interne de l'union
européenne ce que vous disiez ou là
effectivement les états font consensus
pour condamner les actions de la russie
ont fait consensus concernant le swift
concernant les sanctions mais on va avec
une prudence relative et c'est pour ça
que cette deuxième option était sur la
table de reconnaître immédiatement et
bien là quand des dessus et la
candidature de l'ukraine au niveau de
l'union européenne alors justement
guillaume klossa vous avez signé une
tribune dans le monde sur ce thème
appelant à une reconnaissance officielle
de l'ukraine comme état candidat à
l'union pourquoi ça me semble important
il faut accélérer il faut il faut casser
un peu les jeux c'est du réel il ya deux
choses dit est ce que peuvent faire les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement y est ce
que peut faire la société civile et moi
comme comme comme citoyens partageant
des valeurs et partageant des valeurs
avec les ukrainiens et ayant conscience
de l'histoire de ce continent je pense
qu'il était important de donner un
signal pour dire de la société civile on
souhaite que vous fassiez fassiez partie
de la famille parce que qu'est ce que
veulent les ukrainiens comme ce que
voulaient les polonais en 89 c'est être
des autres citoyens européens comme les
autres ce qui explique que même quand il
ya les frères kazinsky au pouvoir ou
quand il ya or banon hongrie ben les
citoyens de ces pays sont massivement
propre un ils veulent être des européens
comme les autres c'est la puissance de
l'idée européenne et pour moi ce message
s'adressait directement au peuple craint
d'ailleurs il a est remis a été diffusée
sur les réseaux sociaux pour dire vous
faites partie de la famille donc
continuer à vous battre c'est ça le
sujet c'est moi je pense que la société
et les citoyens peuvent faire de la
politique à leur manière en complément
des chefs d'état qui eux peuvent ou ne
peuvent pas s'engager parce que ça crée
des sacrés des risques et ensuite oui
c'est plus facile de reconnaître le
statut de deux futurs états membres
parce que c'est le début d'une adepte
d'une adhésion est ce qu'il faut le
faire maintenant je pense que les chefs
d'état et gouvernement ne le feront pas
maintenant parce qu'il ya un risque est
ce que on doit se dire un chiffon rouge
supplémentaire qu'on agit de devant oui
oui oui mais est ce que est ce que nous
citoyens européens on doit pas
massivement signer cet appel et le
partager oui bien sûr parce que ça nous
pousse à être audacieux et ça contribue
à un espace public européen
ouvert sur le monde c'est ce qu'on est
en train de faire
c'est quelque part sortir de cette
période de 70 ans d'histoire où l'europe
n'avait ni récit ni volonté de se
projeter géopolitiquement et là on
montre que les citoyens ils sont prêts
je pense que c'est un signal très fort
aussi pour soutenir le volontarisme des
dirigeants de l'union européenne
au delà des manuels patron qui qui qui
qui avait quelques parcs ouverts la voie
mais il est important que la communauté
des dirigeants de l'union aille dans le
même sens et c'est ça le message qu'on
voulait donner avec cet appel alors je
voudrais qu'on termine ce premier débat
autour de la question nucléaire cette
menace brandie par le président russe
sont l'écoutent
j'ordonne au ministre de la défense
et aux chefs d'états majors de mettre
les forces de dissuasion de l'armée
russe en régime spécial d' alerte au
combat
patricia allemonière est ce que est ce
que je lisais
ce matin hier matin dans le parisien la
réaction d'un général français qui
disait là le conflit change de nature
avec cette déclaration est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça
c'est difficile c'est difficile à dire à
de répondre directement comme ça en tout
cas est la dissuasion nucléaire
nucléaire est basée sur le principe
qu'on ne s'attaque pas sachant que
l'autre a mais en général on ne me
laisse pas comme ça d' utiliser et là on
est passé à une phase de propos et ce
qui est intéressant dans cette
déclaration dans cette dernière
déclaration café vladimir poutine c'est
que il justifie de mettre en alerte et
force de dissuasion parce que les des
propos tenus par l'occident pratiquement
ne sont outranciers et agressif mais on
parle pas d'armes on parle pas de guerre
on parle d'eux propos de commentaires
donc qu'un chef d'état met en alerte ses
forces de dissuasion donc nucléaire on
peut penser parce que les propos tenus
par d'autres chefs d'état il les juge
agressif et à son encontre ça pose des
questions et alors beaucoup de gens
effectivement s'interroge de cette
dernière par rapport à cette dernière
déclaration en se demandant mais
pourquoi vladimir poutine va-t-il aussi
loin parce qu'une fois qu'on a fait ce
genre de déclarations jusqu'où peut-on
aller lors certains expliquent en fait
il veut pas dire là les super bombe
atomique mais juste des petites bombes
qui pourrait lâcher comme ça à temps une
tête de missile dans sur l'ukraine un
chacun y va de son explication
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est que tour
de vladimir poutine vous avez des gens
très inquiétants
qui sont favorables qui ont dit déjà
dans de très nombreux débats de
télévision qu'il fallait recourir
justement à ces petites bombes à ces
missiles nucléaires qui font des dégâts
sur remettons des dizaines de kilomètres
carrés mais pas plus et que c'était très
utile et dans les débats ou sur les
plateaux de télévision ils tiennent ces
propos et certains entourent vladimir
peut donc qui se trouve au milieu de
gens qui essayent de porter cette
tendance quant à savoir si l'homme lui a
perdu sa raison ou si au contraire il
est très rationnel d'y continuer très
fasciné ce qu'on a toujours cru il veut
simplement nous faire peur moi je suis
pas dans cette seule la vraie question
est ce que ce n'est pas de savoir si
c'est une démonstration de force ou si
c'est un aveu de faiblesse est-ce qu'on
est au point faible non j'en entends
bien mais pour qu'au bout de quatre
jours d'une opération mise des
militaires d'une intervention qui devait
durer que quelques jours ils soient
obligés de brandy 1 ou d'agiter ça me
rend alors qu'il y avait pas de guerre
encore et elle à la première réunion
avec emmanuel macron la conférence de
presse il l'a déjà agité donc c 'est
dance arena
supplémentaires en dix ans je mets en a
l'air mais il a déjà maille agité cette
même d'accord avec mathieu on peut y
voir un signe de faiblesse aussi
déguisés aussi mist mais je pense que je
pense qu'à des deux paradoxalement je
pense qu'il ya des deux c'est à dire que
d'un côté il a quand même une il a quand
même une force et il sait qu'en face de
lui les occidentaux les européens ne
vont pas sorti alors leur armée puisque
on le dit dans tous les sens du la
prévenue etc il est donc quelque part et
selon il se sait je pense paradoxalement
qu'on est le fait qu'on lui donnait
quelque part une green light un qu'on
lui dit mais ça se sont tus risque rien
parce qu'on n'ira pas fait que comme
c'est un homme tactique et qu'ils
profitent d'opportunités il est allé
plus loin que ce qu'il avait anticipé et
finalement il se rend compte que il est
pas si solide que ça parce que il ne
maîtrise pas sa jeunesse il ne maîtrise
pas autant qu'il le pensait son son son
opinion publique il a quand même demandé
qu'on enlève alors je sais plus quel
jour mais tous les portables aux jeunes
soldats qui les avaient au début c'est
qu'il y ait dans mille îles à hilla il a
vraiment peur que de ne plus maîtriser
l'information et ça je pense que ça ça
génère aussi des comportements qui sont
pas rationnels et ou alors qu'ils seront
ultra rationnelle vous me direz mais
aussi le fait que kitty écoute il qu'y a
t'il comme contre-pouvoir il ya plus de
presse il ya plus d'oligarques qui
l'écoutent il ya plus de généraux qui
puisse dire quelque chose de
contradictoire donc ça fait que parfois
on dit des bêtises parce que une parole
publique elle a besoin m
je suis personne n'est dans la tête
devait tenir tranquille mais quand vous
sortez quelque chose comme ça c'est
quelque chose j'ai pas et qu'à une
intention donc est-ce que l'intention
c'est de dire tout le monde sait que la
russie d'une puissance nucléaire ça
n'est pas une information dont que
c'était un monde y débite wild eyes on
pourrait considérer de toute façon en a
l'air
et en ahl et qu'en face les autres
puissances nucléaires doivent être aussi
en alerte même s'ils ne le disent pas
parce que on veut pas être dans cette
surenchère de communication qui créent
les escalades les sens et quand je dis
tant il est tout les services secrets
sont sur les écoutes pour voir justement
qu'est ce qu'il entend par alerte parce
que ça on ne le sait pas encore où les
animés mais juste préciser ma pensée
parce que le mot n'était pas adapté mais
pour moi dire ça parce que ça c'est
entendu de l'opinion publique russe et
français et françaises mais russes
notamment
c'est quelque part se déjuger par
rapport à son opinion publique parce que
dire voilà je suis prêt à lancer l' arme
nucléaire à sortir les parce que il ya
des propos désobligeants à mon égard je
pense que c'est de nature à ébranler
quand même l'opinion publique alors
russe d'une certaine justement dernière
question pour vous christine du moins
clément / sur l' isolement évidemment de
devenir poutine mais peut-être aussi de
la russie avec toutes les sanctions que
que l'on a détaillé avec cette menace
nucléaire il ya deux façons de l'analyse
et si on parle de l'opinion russe il ya
le réflexe patriotique ou nationalistes
et puis il ya
voilà des cercles de pouvoir qui
pourrait se dire mais c'est pas possible
ça fait des années qu'on essaye de
construire autre chose et la lumière
président mais tout à plat comment vous
l'analysez vous
il ya plusieurs choses et notamment
quand vous parlez de des déclarations
concernant est bien l'armé nucléaire il
ya quand même peut-être quelque chose
sur lequel lequel revenir dans ses
déclarations il explique que c'est suite
à une agression de propos agressifs qui
touche la russie or la doctrine d'emploi
de l'armé nucléaire russe est très
différente de la doctrine d'emploi
française par exemple c'est à dire que
vous êtes
dans le droit d'utiliser l'armé
nucléaire à partir du moment où l'état
bruce est estimé être en danger il ya
différents niveaux dallaire tournant au
niveau de 2 sur 4 donc ce qui peut
rentrer dans cette justification là et
ça va aussi dans un ensemble de discours
que l'on a depuis maintenant le début de
la guerre où il est il est obligé d'y
aller c'est ce qu'il sait ce qu'il a
expliqué dans ses différentes
déclarations nous sommes obligés d'y
aller nous n'avons pas le choix sinon
nous seront attaqués nous avons la
défense de ces peuples là donc il est
cohérent là dedans dans le discours
porté par rapport à la russie et par
rapport à la population hausse et quant
à revenir sur bien la population bien
c'est un vaste débat parce que il y a
effectivement vladimir poutine le
kremlin et les russes de russie la
question étant de savoir entre ceux qui
sont réellement informé de la situation
2 pourquoi de l'histoire de ce qui se
passe quel est leur niveau d'information
là dessus pour pouvoir essayer de savoir
de poser un jugement il y a plusieurs
informations qui ont été rapportés et
qui nécessitent encore d'être recroiser
d'être re vérifier comme qui expliquait
que et bien effectivement beaucoup de
jeunes militaires russes conscrits ne
savait pas réellement ce qu'il faisait
ici et leurs familles ne savais pas
qu'ils étaient en ukraine pour certains
pour beaucoup il était temps manoeuvre
vous étiez pas encore avec nous mais on
l'a évoqué au début de ce débat merci
beaucoup merci d'y avoir
isildur1 clément j'appelle le titre de
votre livre toujours des manipulations
des conflits armées modernes aux guerres
économiques c'est publié chez v à
édition merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette première partie de ce
sens public